[Music]
hello
so today I'm going to be talking about
interviewing which is really just the
tip of a very large iceberg which we're
talking about the whole iceberg
I guess this talk is not just for you if
you're looking for a job but if you
interview people
I'm Ryan labove I currently work for
envoy where we challenge the status quo
of workplace technology it's a Bay Area
company super fun most of the time I'm
doing ember and node stuff but since
it's a startup I do a little bit of
everything this talk kind of started
it's a certain point in my career I was
started interviewing more and more
people as we're trying to hire and I
would see people make the same like I
don't want to say mistakes but it's like
I had to look and I found really
interesting things about people but they
just weren't coming across in the
interview so I would have to do a lot of
like poking in their github looking on
their social media and asking them a lot
of questions actually get kind of the
best to shine through I was like I wish
I could give a talk that kind of just
like put it all on the table from like
my perspective and helped people get a
job so given that we have 45 minutes I'm
gonna kind of lay out some goals I want
to give you more or less a map to
getting the job you want this is not
like just your first job but this is
like a career trajectory that you should
be able to keep coming back to you so I
don't care if you're a junior dev or if
you're like you have a really good job
you're looking for something else or if
you have a job and you're trying to help
get people to come work for you I think
there's something for everybody
the hard thing here is there's like
thousands of pieces of advice I could
say about this and like it's trying to
distill and present in a way that makes
sense so I'm gonna start with a story
this may seem a little bit unrelated to
what we're talking about but I promise
it's not there's this really indie kind
of anime short film called the reward on
Vimeo and it starts off with these like
two super ordinary dudes sitting at
sitting
village in this like completely crazy
hero rolls through the town they're both
like me and I want to be like this
person and on the way out of town the
the hero drops this map with an X on it
and like they fight over the map and
they end up like let's go on the journey
together
and they start off in like some really
basic places and they like find these
magic weapons they start taking on new
challenges a lot of time unsuccessfully
a lot of time having like bail their
crazy friends who are like doing it with
them over and over again but like
eventually your friend that you're on
the journey with like kind of helps you
back and you start like having some wins
and taking on bigger risks and like
before you know it you're like riding on
ocean of lava on a fleet of narwhals
having completed some epic quest and
like what what we see as the journey
progresses is like in each frame these
people kind of like change and like they
don't see this but we see them becoming
the heroes that they originally saw
riding through their village and like
they just keep fighting like crazy
bosses and blindly charging towards this
X and when they get there there's
nothing there it's just a literally a
big X on the ground which is all the map
advertised really but there's this big
mirror and they kind of realized along
the way it was like the journey the
journey has made them into these heroes
and that was like the reward right and
then like it ends with them riding
through the same town with like some
dopey looking kids looking at them and
like to these kids they're like the
heroes now and these kids are like how
do i how do I become like you and you
see one of them slowly like slip the map
out of the satchel with the X on it that
started the whole journey for them and
the kids like repeat the same thing over
again this is exactly like my journey of
programming it's like a it's a little
bit ridiculous for like the premise of
this talk but we'll see you'll see if
you don't already see so kind of like
revisiting the goals for today given
this map we have with the big X I want
to help you see like where you are in
like help debunk some
the myths of the journey to help you get
the job and this is all leading up to
the fearless interview some anti goals
I'm not gonna teach you computer science
in 30 minutes it's not possible and I'm
also not gonna help you fake your way
into a job so anyways let's get started
the quest map I kind of broke it down
into six six parts one is learning how
to code two is getting your first tech
job three is preparing to look for a new
job
four is the job hunt five what we're
leading up to is the fearless interview
and six is kind of a postscript of being
at the X and throughout this talk I've
talked to literally all of my friends
who code and had them just give advice
that they found helpful along the way so
it's a you'll see quotes from a lot of
lot of randos that I really respect so
learning how to code this is your magic
weapons that you find it's interesting I
was talking with John Moses of one of my
friends and he's actually giving a talk
about this in a few weeks so I'm not
gonna like try to go over at all he's
got a great series on it he's gonna
speak more about it in about a week or
two or three I don't know but my TL DR
is like learn a language build internet
things meet developers share what you
build I personally learned how to to
code on this this book called the Ruby
on Rails tutorial where we built Twitter
from scratch free code camp is great
there's another one by Colt steel I
highly recommend you build Yelp from
scratch that's not the point though it's
just like it's a lot less important
where you start as long as you pick
something and finish it that's kind of
my point for learning how to code after
your boot camp experience this is where
the real work begins
you need to build something on your own
if you don't know what to build I
recommend starting with a blog because
it's like really easy to like you know
what a blog is and you can build a very
small or a very complex one you can ship
it people can read it you have users you
have something to talk about like my
friend Jordan Smith says be honest keep
learning and talk about what you learned
so after you build something cool this
is where you start signing up for
lightning talks free code camp okay CJ
is the Ruby group wherever you can talk
you need to share with share what you
learn just keep building things get as
far as you can on projects make them
dumb make them fun make them something
you use there's this guy Ira Glass he
has this little short story called the
gap and it's about creatives about how
like when you start in a new field you
like like I want to be a painter it's
like I see these amazing paintings and
then you paint this just like terrible
thing it's like how do I get from here
to here and everybody goes through this
it's exactly the same with programming
and his answer is do a lot of work a
huge volume of work and that volume of
work is what helps you close the gap and
eventually the quality of your work will
catch your ambitions so if you're still
stuck on this West boss has this thing
called JavaScript 30 you build 30s from
all things in JavaScript over 30 days
you'll probably make today 13 and be
building something really interesting
that you like and like you'll just go
off on this tangent that's what you want
that's great
that's like a sign that you're doing the
right thing so the boss battle for
learning how to code can you use get in
github do you have like a side project
that you can point to that's like I
built this thing and it's on the
internet now I can prototype stuff in
HTML and CSS I can solve basic coding
challenges with JavaScript and also I
understand the basic workings of an API
this is like a pretty good start which
segues into getting your first tech job
so especially if you go through free
code camp you build some stuff on your
own you want to get paid like you want
to start working in tech and so before
your first step tech job I personally
felt like everything I did was just a
string of terrible failures with
programming and then somehow like as
soon as you learn your first tech job
this is where you feel like you're on
the fleet of NAR whales cruising through
the lava sea it's just like I don't know
it's really big and it feels a lot like
getting your big break but a question I
get a lot is how do I know I'm ready for
my first job in the industry so this is
where I have to remind you everybody
started somewhere every
was a junior nobody came out just
programming so my rule of thumb is if
you can build something useful
you're probably hireable to somebody you
don't have to know everything you just
have to be able to add value to the team
that you're joining that's like a really
important thing be very open about your
current skill level you don't have to
hire lied about anything but also don't
undersell yourself like especially if
you come from a job that has like a
customer service background a lot of
programmers after 10 years turn into
like sea creatures and though I can't
talk to people so like you bring very
valuable skills to table just by being
able to engage with the customers it's
like these are very valuable things that
you bring to the team so I really like
Queen Carmen says it's ok to say you
don't know something much better than
making something up specific warnings
for your first job in tech you want to
make sure the team you're joining is
ready to bring on juniors some questions
I suggest asking one do you have other
juniors on your team - are there people
on staff who were a junior but now we're
no longer juniors that are still with
you three how did what kind of
mentorship do you have for juniors how
do you make sure that they continue to
progress in four are there clear job
bans how and how often would we
reevaluate whether I'm still a junior
and I'll say personally an envoy this is
something we always come back to you and
it's like I think it's hard for
companies to get this right and so it's
like don't feel bad if you're at a
company it's like we're trying to do the
mentorship program the important part is
just to keep asking yourself these
questions and trying to make sure that
answer continues to improve John Moses
Minh says get a friend that can get you
a job honestly this is probably the
hardest step in the whole process so
harder than like getting building that
compiler or doing weird video game stuff
is getting your first job that's like
pretty deep for somebody who's been in
the industry probably at least 10 years
so boss battle first tech job from this
job you're gonna want things on your
resume you're gonna want to launch
something monitor actual software
maintain it deal with
summers these are all skills that you
won't get from anywhere else
specifically you want to make sure
you're continuing to gain more
experience collaborating with other
programmers this is something that's
very unique to actually having a
programming job and at the end of this
you really want to make sure that you no
longer consider yourself a junior so
that willing leads me to my next point
it's preparing to look for a new job
this there's a lot of overlap between
the first job but this is where I find
is actually on my personal journey was
like the hardest point because I worked
for a company for maybe six years and
like it at some point I felt really
stuck and it took me a long time to
figure out how to continue to ramp up my
skills to get ready for the next stage
in my career and again going back to our
metaphor like this is where you're kind
of like I'm kind of a grizzled veteran
already I probably don't see this if
you've been working in a job for one to
two years you've changed your shipping
software whereas before you or not this
is this is like massive changes in you
so I break this down into three parts
and I'll go over them one is to prove
your T which we'll talk about because
that sounds really weird slash are slash
into a context to is get the junior out
of your title and three is improve your
coding chops so there's this idea of
t-shaped people somebody came up with it
I don't know who they are but if you
think about the letter T it's got like a
horizontal long top with a long vertical
stem and essentially what you're wanting
to say is I have been experienced I have
been exposed to a lot of things in
programming but I'm really good at this
one thing and this is where like
t-shaped people I will hire these people
all day every day and so this is where
you want to say like yeah I've made a
couple api's I have done like some
DevOps see things and I've built some
front ends but I really love ember
jeaious and that's where I spend most of
my time contributing and so really this
is like being going from a junior to
just a software engineer this is
probably the hardest thing figure out
what you're interested in and then work
on developing the sim of your T so let's
say you're really into X how do you
prove the
some things that I recommend is like
open source you'll probably using tools
that revolve around X so like if you
like d3 go sign up for the deep 3 repo
look at other libraries built on d3
start trying to contribute back to these
things write an article comparing d3 to
three.js I don't think that's actually a
good comparison but anyways complete
like one serious side project that lets
that shine blog about this how do you do
a non-trivial d3 project from scratch
even if you feel like it's repetitive
and people have done it it's still
important for you to do it
and just for example when I was like I'm
really into ember jeaious I was like how
do I actually prove that to people and
then I went looked this is open source
I've done and launched projects on my
own here's projects that I've
contributed to actual full side projects
articles talks it's just like if this is
a court case it would be really easy to
prove that I really like in verge is
it's a very specific thing but when
somebody's like I need somebody to do in
purchase and I'm like here's my resume
they're like I want you to help me so
like that's really what you wear you
want to get um getting junior out of
your title what's the easiest way to get
junior out of your title stop calling
yourself a junior that seems like really
dumb advice but like after you get your
first job drop it you're not a junior
anymore you're always just a software
engineer every organization is gonna
have different standards from junior to
senior so don't try to sell yourself to
something just like explain why I'm an
engineer here's what I love some things
you can do to really help you with this
also is have a regular practice of
learning from people and resources that
are better than you and practice the
things you learn and then focus on one
thing at a time I'm just gonna throw a
couple things that I've historically
found really helpful I'll publish the
slides and you can refer to them later
if you're new to computer science and
have a non-traditional background that
bass es podcast is amazing
it breaks down usually like pomp and
academic things like data structures and
B trees and traversal of recursive blah
blah was like breaks it down into waste
is really easy
Stan you don't know je yes it's like a
great like I do JavaScript every day and
I want to know more about this Eric
Elliot writes on on medium a lot his
stuffs great there's this book called
pooter which is practical
object-oriented design and Ruby it's
like there's a lot of great like
architecture books you can start reading
and starting and start like improving
like different domains of your
programming skills Ruby tapas fun fun
function is a great javascript one
there's more this guy super grumpy but
as screen caster great up case is
another one that's like really good this
is where I stole though like get the
junior out of your title it's literally
like you watch really good programmers
pear on hard problems and you end up
learning an amazing amount by doing this
and when you're comfortable enough which
should be now read the open-source repos
you use it's my sock one source
reference I promise so open source
projects are literally like play books
about how to make the things you like so
you can just like read how to do it and
it's like oh my gosh I can make d3 now I
don't know why I chose to e3 I never
used to e3 and learn how to use a
debugger I don't know that's a hard one
but it's useful and also learned how to
do TDD same so and then other things
like when you're ready to actually start
applying for jobs you need to make sure
that your your coding chops are like up
to snuff which is like more of a matter
of discipline do an hour of hacker rank
every day read the cracking the code
interview book this book is amazing like
nobody remembers all this stuff but if I
had to look for a new job I would get a
six-pack of redbull and read this over
one weekend and like that's where I
would start imposters handbook is
another great one and then interview
cake again I'll post all these later so
like if you're looking for specific
resources reach out to me I will help
you match like what I think would make
the most sense for your app okay so
preparing to look for a job you can
prove to me you're interested in one or
two very specific technical things this
is a very important thing you have a
consistent practice of learning from
high-quality sources like hour a day two
hours on the weekend whatever it is like
continue to learn things and not you can
also easily solve a wide variety of
programming challenges okay now we're on
to the job hunt this is all about
networking positioning negotiation I
really just wanted to put this in my
slides it's not really relevant to what
we're talking about networking heroic
Eric says go to meetup in conferences
this is where I've gotten most of my
jobs from Alex an engineer I work with
says meet actual engineers for your
plying message me and buy me coffee I
will tell you exactly what things are
like this is great advice like I
actually knew somebody who the way that
they would start applying for a job they
would find an open-source repo for a
company they wouldn't apply for start
opening issues and pull requests against
it and use that to like apply like what
open-source have you done well have you
seen your projects you didn't update
this and I did like it's it's an OK way
to do that this is also extremely
opinionated but in my opinion the best
jobs come from direct recommendations
then applying for companies you like and
then literally everything else and I'm
not gonna like poopoo on recruiters or
job boards or anything they're all great
but if you have a friend who will say I
like working at my job
that's huge like that's somebody you
want to work with that is like the
easiest way to know you're getting into
a situation that you'll like so again
make connections contribute to open
source go to meetups go to conferences
speak of me up some conferences if you
can apply for contracting positions at
companies this is easy because if you do
a bad job they don't have to pay you
after a week like be like hey I would
love to do some consulting for your
contracting for you and then Twitter
like a madman or mad person the last
time I tweeted that I was out of a job
I had three job offers from Twitter just
because I heated about programming stuff
this is like an amazing thing
so positioning what kind of company do
you want to work for what matters to you
do you want to be remote does salary
matter it's a tech stack matter this is
your team matter this kind of needs to
inform what type of jobs you start to
look for startups big companies
consultancies going out on your own
do you want to work for like oh you or a
government thing when you kind of have
this like if you want to work at macro
corp like update your LinkedIn don't
have weird stuff on social media buy
some nice business casual clothes do
whatever these people do like be like
them
this is this is a job you want this is a
lifestyle you want like figure out how
these people work and just like like
emulate them in a way that's not like
I'm forgetting who I am but like these
are the people you want to fit in with
so like start fitting in with them now
if you want to work at startup Li like
by a macbook and hoodie like but you say
like start to taking pictures you latte
and post them on Instagram these are
like these will help you fit in and kind
of understand how these people think and
work again know how to fit in know how
to be yourself know how to stand out so
when you're applying when you're like
working on companies you're like I want
to apply it startup layer Mac micro Corp
macro Corp like you need to kind of do
some research on these companies what
are their core values their mission
statement what is their financial health
key personnel Google the company and
figure out what what they say on their
social media figure out who their
competitors are and when you start
interviewing like I know people know
that they're interviewing with me at
least a week ahead of time it's like
it's really easy to figure out what I'm
into you so if you start like if you
open up with like react versus Amber
joke I'll probably be like oh this guy
is funny he's no city's like he's
controlling me like that's great then
for every company you interview to you
need to add them to like I have this
like spreadsheet there's actually a
better way to explain this it needs to
look like this like when you're
interviewing you just have like you're
connecting all these dots and like
looking at all of your opportunities so
in negotiation it's super hard but your
salary negotiation which routinely takes
less than five minutes
to conclude has an outsized influence on
what your compensation is the difference
in five thousand or ten thousand dollars
to a company is chump change it's
nothing it's an HR gimmick so like you
need to do a little bit of research
about what companies are offering
because they game they game the system
to give you as little as possible
not everybody but like you just need to
you need to look out for yourself also
like apply for a wide variety of
positions specifically if this is one of
your first jobs the only successful way
to leverage your salary up higher that
I've seen is to use offers from other
companies it is not it is not playing
like you're not playing anybody like the
companies are playing against each other
this this guy right here he was a
professional poker player who turned
into a a like software engineer and he
basically started getting like $80,000
offers and he this whole blog post is
how is eventually he ended up getting a
$250,000 offer from like companies
playing against each other which I'm not
saying like that's a rule I wish I had
that kind of offer I don't but like it's
interesting you should definitely go do
a little bit of research here and again
it should feel like this if it if it
doesn't feel like this you're not you
know hunting for jobs right let's see I
actually don't care but right now this
is actually a really good story but
Stephanie Hobart kind of talks about her
whole like career trajectory so go read
this later but I'm kind of wanting to
run out of time so again the job hunt
this is all like super basic stuff have
a resume post on social media looking
for a job portfolio side projects and
personal side are up to date and
operational nothing's weird saan your
social media network constantly and
apply everywhere and so 34 minutes and
we're finally to the fearless interview
and it's going to be a lot like the X in
the story you may be very surprised at
how little is here why because your
whole journey in your software
development career is what allows you to
have fearless interviews it's the side
projects it's the open source it's the
networking that's what prepares you to
fight the boss battle if you're level
one and you're trying to go against this
like deity dude there's nothing you can
do to prepare you just have to go kill
picks in the woods until you level up
like but that being said I will talk a
little bit about
the logistics of interview because I
think it helps a lot there's usually
three parts intros some type of
challenge and then questions at the end
so this is maybe my favorite piece of
advice at any of my programmer friends
gave me be prepared to answer or
volunteer the what is the one thing you
built that you're most proud of
David said if people can answer this
well that's the leading indicator if
you'll hire them or not and it's never
let him down specifically he looks
forward you care about what you're
building do you understand what you're
building is it's something that I
personally can connect with also on
intros my little piece of logistical
advice if you're signing up for a car
your son if you're trying to interview
at a company sign up for their service
have a critical opinion about what they
do understanding a little bit of
business context can really drive the
conversation when you're interviewing so
if it's like an arrow tracking software
sign up for them and then their
competitor like one of the biggest
things I've ever got dinged on with an
interview is I applied it a place I
didn't sign up for it I didn't really
know what they do and like the first
thing was like tell me about why you
wanted to interview that specifically
what did you think about our product and
it's like you basically can't walk your
way out or around that so like if you do
this it's one of the like most
insightful pieces that you can do to
help prepare the challenge this is like
people's most stressed out like if you
read the title probably what you thought
I was going to talk about it's like 300
tips to defeat the programming challenge
and the thing is like there are some
it's like read this book and do this
like but but there's no tricks it's like
hard work and then you just have to be
ready I will tell you the challenges
typically come in three flavors there's
usually like the especially if you're
doing front-end stuff like react or
ember or view it's like build a
component like an autocomplete or star
rating UI which is where things like the
JavaScript already come in handy like as
you're interviewing just build some
dumb things so you're ready to do that
the other one it's like building a crud
app so like specifically with full stack
or back in positions I would expect that
you could test drive like basic crud
operations on an API like that's a
pretty common common challenge and so
like this is stuff like to do MVC the
blog and then another one is explain a
solution to hypothetical problem this is
easily the most frustrating one because
it's super objective no subjective it's
like I don't like white we don't do
white boarding in our interview process
other than like like if you want to like
explain a system with like some
flowcharts there's like a white board
available but I think white board coding
is just dumb but I mean if you use that
it is dumb so don't use that but but if
you're interviewing for a place like
again I think I don't know if Google
still does this but like when I read
through this it's like part of their
coding problem is like pseudo code on
the white board so like if you want to
work for a place and they're a really
good company
like sometimes their interview process
just has this you need to be prepared
for it it's all part that's like part of
the game and again read this book
cover-to-cover
build dumb things and you'll be fine
I've never been in a coding like I've
never been an interview so first of all
for your first couple of interviews
you're gonna do a bad job probably I did
like a lot of people do this is just
like you don't go from like I learned to
play guitar on YouTube to I'm playing
with Celine Dion in one set like you
just have to play like you have to kind
of hat you're gonna have some interviews
you're gonna have to kind of figure out
how to do things but as long as you're
preparing you'll get you get better
every time Union one of my favorite
interviewers says practice going through
the problem and thinking out loud
practice is explaining what you're
trying to do when you're coding or
explaining then coding which is actually
a good skill Estevan who is another
amazing interviewer says practice on
things like a crank be ready to solve an
algorithm probably know the difference
know how to explain the efficiency of
what you're doing which if you want to
know how to do that
read the green book
for me have your ide and programming
environment ready if you say you do
ember
you better have umbrella installed and
be ready to go if you say you do react
have create react app installed and
ready to go we usually try to have like
bootstrapped environments ready but
there was a time when we didn't and
there's plenty of people who don't so
like if it's like hey I want to see you
because something in react and you're
not set up your burning like 20 minutes
of your interview trying to figure out
how to get something set just like it
looks bad even though it shouldn't be
bad on you it does look bad and then
questions always have a physical list of
questions you're wanting to ask the
employer make a couple of them personal
based on things you've read and make a
couple of them very general there's
usually some time when the interviewer
goes do you have any questions for me on
most of our like more senior people this
is one of the biggest things that they
look at when they interview people is
what questions they asked back questions
I usually ask which I think you're like
pretty good to write on your everytime
list that you can just like have ready
is like how do your engineer sell
disagreements what is your biggest
concern going into the next quarter how
this is this one's actually amazing how
likely are you to recommend that one of
your friends works here because like if
they're like like if you go back to like
where I talked about where can you get
the best job is from your friend that
that you know likes their job so that
kind of helps you understand the culture
how does communication work here
describe the company culture this is
pretty vague but like if people have
like dirty laundry to air they're gonna
do it here and you're gonna know you
want to know this at a time what's your
favorite and least favorite thing about
working here how do you know you're
doing a good job at work again and then
like have some other ones like if you
read that they just closed the big
funding round would be like House of
House closing the funding round changed
your hiring process like what is the
morale like after you just closed this
massive series beer or something I just
be ready to talk about things that these
people know about you'll make a personal
connection with them and you'll seem
like you're already on the team and
finally if you use sublime text
by a licensed before you interview with
me
if you click save in the police by
sublime cop pops up it's just like
losing points for no reason that's kind
of personal preference but so again the
fearless interview review your dossier
before every interview that Evernote
filed that you have on this company
that's like you've done your research
your local coding environment should be
set up you've solved hundreds of
algorithm problems and done dozens of
dummy components and apps which it just
happens over time your networking
constantly at meetups and conferences
you're regularly applying on job boards
listing sites and through recruiters and
everything else you can think of if you
do these things you can get a job at
whatever company you want so your thanks
if you're somebody who has this fantasy
job I love my job and I think that I'm
there like I'm sure like I'll think that
about every job from here but like like
I just love what I do now I work
remotely I've got two kids my water
cooler is having goldfish with my
three-year-old I love ember that's like
I get to work with my favorite
technology I love my team help other
people get there there's a lot of people
that are making less than they're
capable of right now getting into a
program the the technology industry can
amplify their quality of life
it can help it can be the difference
between my family has enough to make it
and not so like have us having
programming jobs if you have them help
bootstrap people to get into these jobs
like I think that's part of our
responsibility being in a good job is
helping other people get there so share
your journey there are people looking
like this at you no matter what stage of
the journey you're on encourage the
future heroes and that's where I will
end also if you have finished free code
camp I will happily interview you and
tell you what I think like just to help
get the jitters out so message me on
social media if there's a flood of
people I will find other people to
interview
don't worry about it like if this is
this is your big stumbling block we can
fix that together after a hundred and
seventy four slides I'm curious does
anybody have any questions
okay so the question was if you already
have a job in a non tech industry it's a
pretty good job any specific advice on
people wanting to cut over to the tech
career I think there's basically two
different trains of thought on this one
you need to look at where you are now
and where you're going to be in ten
years and if you hopped over to tech and
took a job a couple you be this is not I
don't think that's a way to decide
anything but I think it helps answer
some questions going back to some of the
other advice I have you bring something
unique to the team so like can you tell
me what field in general you're in right
now for example so if you are doing
supply chain management stuff there's
likely tech opportunities in your field
so when you add oh and I can program
onto your current title it will likely
give you a raise in the same industry
I've seen a lot of people do this where
they essentially take their current job
they pivot it into tech stuff and then
they use that it's like hey I've already
had a tech job and now I'm applying for
another senior position so it's a little
bit of a longer path to the tech
industry but it is a way to like provide
like kind of that like no loss and like
financial wellness Pat does it make
sense what else
trying to think so somebody who is a a
literal author interviewed with me
recently which is not like there's
nothing magic about being an author any
one of us can go on lien pub and publish
like feeding dogs for dummies and like
we're not there right but like I was
actually familiar with their work and we
ended up solving some completely
unrelated challenge it so it's weird
because it's like the people who really
impressed me is very seldom about the
actual interviewing it's more about like
the conversation around it it's a bad
answer
let me think again interviewing is very
hard not many people impressed me that's
that's the honest truth
that's why I wrote this talk like people
so I'll tell you I'll tell you
conversely there have been people who
have not impressed me an interview who
we've hired that have really impressed
me in the job that's probably a better
answer so it's like I think that's
really we've worked a lot on our
interviewing process to make it like we
want to capture that yeah next question
so I think like in the green book the
general rule of thumb is six months I
don't have personal experience with that
I think this is so like especially with
places like Google or Facebook like it's
pretty much accepted you're not gonna
make it for the first pass so like
applying again at a place is not bad the
thing that I would tell you if you apply
again you need to kind of have some like
change to your story
so like again this is why I'm a big fan
of side projects or if you get another
job that kind of helps like like change
like I was here and now I'm here and I
think I'm a much more compelling case to
work with you that type of thing yeah
anything else okay okay
so this is where I go and look at their
social media this is like a big thing
like I want to know who like the people
also like you know how I said the best
jobs come from your friends the best
candidates also come from your friends
so I think number one is like if
somebody is Rick like I respect Bob and
Bob has recommended Sallie work here
like going into that usually Sally is
gonna be a better candidate than like
Rando
so like any recommendations through
relationships are usually very good
specifically for people I feel like our
gaming me for us in particular like I
look at their so if it's like a coding
thing I'll look at their personal github
and I actually will be like I see you
worked on this project let's work on it
together like when people game you they
tend to be very good at the interview so
you need to do something non-traditional
to break up the interview process so
like when he when you open an issue on
one of their repos and you're like hey
for our interview can you explain how
this works to me
that's they're gonna be expecting like
the standard challenge so like I think
that's where you need to kind of like
does that make sense are you able
yeah sorry are you able to do any
research ahead of time into your
candidates mm-hmm yeah if you are
concerned at all
I think one really good thing you can do
is specifically if it's like like if you
have any red flags I always offer like
can we contract for a while instead that
doesn't work for everybody but it's a
lot lower risk to bring on somebody as a
contractor or consultant and actually
get to know like yep and so I think also
the thing like if we have a specific
technical recruiter and she's great
I think if she was here probably one of
the things she would say is like Rega
going through you're like where are you
sourcing these people from like you
should also talk with the people who you
currently work with and be like hey is
anybody that you know looking to make a
change or looking to get into this
because again your best candidates will
come from people that you know so if you
if you love working with somebody you
will probably love working with their
friends
yep and so the comment was like you're
not miked are you I'll repeat the
comment in the comment was like in my
experience the hiring price slower more
thorough hiring process since a yield
higher quality candidates I would say
this is true also our hiring process is
like at minimum for
back-to-back-to-back-to-back cut 1 our
coding challenges which i think is
brutal like when I did that I was like
this is insane
but I'll tell you the this team that I'm
working on is some of the best software
engineers I've ever worked with so it's
like probably true
sure so the question was like I I'm a
pretty private person is it a big
turn-off for people trying to hire me of
all of my social medias lockdown I
highly see to the if you want to work at
macro core be like a macro Corp you can
work up startup Li you need to be like a
startup person I think that what I would
do in your case specifically with like
Twitter if as you're learning things and
reading articles and like you need to
treat Twitter more it's like a knowledge
share so like if it's the case where you
make a different Twitter that's not
personal you publish little todayI
learns and things I think that's
actually really important because it
will help your employer know that you're
engaging with the community and so it's
like you don't have to like put like any
personal stuff on there like you know
I've got kids and I very seldom post kid
pictures on Twitter ever even though
they're adorable there's like a lot of
creepy people out there and I don't want
you know one across across those paths
but I do think it's very important if
you're trying to get a new job
specifically you have to have some
community presence and so I think I
think about this a lot like if you have
a house and if you have like the massive
privacy fence around the house every
time somebody drives by they're gonna
think it's a creepy creepy family creepy
house even though you could just be
valuing your privacy I think it's a
matter of how you present yourself so
it's like if you like have the nice yard
and the nice face but the privacy fence
in the back I think that's basically
what you want you have to have something
that people can see so they can get to
know you I think that is pretty
important but you don't need to do it in
a way that puts your family at risk at
all okay
so the question was what social media is
best for the tech industry unequivocally
in my experience that would be Twitter
it depends on the industry like LinkedIn
is very important for a lot of people
but like nobody I know uses it Instagram
is never important unless you're like
trying to sell products or wanting
people to know how cool you are and
Facebook tends to be the same it's like
usually highly personal stuff so like I
don't know if any like I'm I'm friends
with all of my co-workers on Twitter but
I'm not friends with any of my
co-workers on Facebook is that kind of
explains any other questions so how
would I get started on Twitter
so if you go on my github there's a
hundred and fifty open repos I open
source literally everything I did it
because I was too cheap to pay and it's
turned out to be one of the biggest like
recruitment ways that people try to
recruit me
so people literally do like automated
searches through github on what you star
and what you have and like you set to
automate their recruiting process like
open source as many things as you're
comfortable with specifically who runs
to the free code camp twitter there's
there's probably some way they could
help you get started too if you like
give a lightning talk then they can
promote it and then I'll retweet it well
you just kind of has to start like that
so like another big thing is conferences
if you go to conferences and meetups try
to follow people they'll usually follow
you back so like I have seven hundred
something followers which has been only
through like I know most of them so like
you just have to go Network like a
madman or a mad person if we any other
questions was this helpful at all okay
great I when I was like looking at this
I'm like I feel like a little bit of
false advertising since I called it the
fearless interview but I don't I thought
was useful or people are just gonna hate
it so I'm glad y'all enjoyed
[Applause]